this morning we're counting down to the
moment the Apollo 11 launched 50 years
ago
no more return but NASA is setting its
sights on a new trip to the moon 2024
some critics argue that that's
unrealistic though amid budget concerns
and already missed deadlines many
presidents have made the promise to go
back and have accomplished it so far
mark Strassmann is in front of the
original Apollo capsules that's in the
visitors center at Kennedy Space Center
that's about two miles from where I am
mark good morning good morning Tony this
is one of the old Apollo capsules this
one actually belonged to Apollo 14 and
inside it three men flew a quarter
million miles to the moon and returned
to earth safely I want to show you now
how NASA plans to go back to the moon
it's been called Apollo on steroids this
is a Ryan NASA's first design of a deep
space crew capsule since the Apollo era
the spaceship astronauts have been
evaluating what NASA has been testing
all the way to splashdowns
we got to see up close at the Johnson
Space Center we put these on to make
sure when we're getting in and out since
we're not astronauts we don't hurt
ourselves we are not astronauts yeah
okay all right from the outside Orion
looks similar to Apollo's capsule come
on down into the step but climb inside
mark Critch oversees NASA's Orion
program the capsule is 50% bigger than
Apollo's roomy enough for four
astronauts so you'll be the pilot today
I'll be the commander at eye-level a
21st century space dashboard just one
example of how this moonshot will be
different when we went last time the
goal was land a person on the moon and
return him safely to earth and we did
that this time it's a little bit
different it's about a sustainable
long-term human space exploration
program Orion would launch on top of an
SLS rocket designed to be more powerful
than the Apollo era saturn v its
destination a mini space station
orbiting the moon called gateway Orion's
crew would dock there and take a lunar
land
down to the moon's surface a handful of
companies are now proposing designs for
gateway watch your head
Frank de Mauro showed us northrop
grumman x' mock-up of a gateway habitat
he oversees space systems for the
company so when the Orion is here this
would be open for the crew to go back
and forth up to four astronauts could
work and live here for up to two months
so if you look up here
that's a berth that a crew member would
go in when it's time to go to sleep the
Apollo astronauts were basically living
out of their car to and from the moon
this is more of a home it's a place
where they can cook their food where
they can gather and socialize but really
do their work but Orion and the SLS
rocket are years behind schedule and
billions over budget in March the Trump
administration fed up ordered NASA to
put Americans back on the moon by 2024
if NASA is not currently capable of
landing American astronauts on the moon
in five years we need to change the
organization not the mission NASA did
just that last week hosting the top two
managers of the Artemis program it was
entirely my decision but at the end of
the day we need to make be very clear
that NASA is committed to cost and
schedule
NASA Administrator Jim bridenstine says
it could take twenty billion additional
dollars over five years to meet that new
deadline my next step is to get the
support from the United States Congress
how realistic is it that we're gonna
have people on the moon by 2024 well I
think it's realistic if the Congress
follows what we have put forward we will
have the first woman and the next man on
the moon in 2024 when this hatch closes
imagine three astronauts squeezed inside
for eight days for the round trip to the
moon now without additional billions
NASA has no chance of going back to the
moon by 2024 an administrator bryden's
Don will be on Capitol Hill tomorrow
Gale to make NASA's case 2024 it will be
here before you know it thank you very
much mark thank you so they say they're
gonna have to they hope to have the
first woman 2024 yeah maybe it could be
why not would you want to go
you want to go to Rica oh man not mine
do you have a daughter
I know you have to come with me yeah
idea of 10 15 20 years so now what does
that space exploration look like is yeah
it's looking a lot more comfortable yeah
that Netflix up the right let's go fifty
years later we're talking about it is
this breathtaking when you see and it
does make you proud to say we did that
yeah no yes did that